en economía escucharán el término
función de producción y quizás al
principio les parezca un poco
intimidante y matemático pero verán que
es una idea bastante básica es la idea
de que podemos tener diversas entradas o
insumos les llamaremos entrada y número
1 entrada y número 2 y podemos continuar
con más entradas y a todas estas
entradas las ingresamos en algún tipo de
proceso que es una función a la que
llamamos efe esta va a describir cuánta
salida o producción se puede obtener con
respecto a esta cantidad de entradas o
insumos también podemos describir esto
en forma un poco más matemática si
recuerdan sus clases de álgebra es
posible que esto les parezca conocido
podemos decir que la salida que
definimos con la letra q en los círculos
económicos va a ser una función de las
diferentes entradas y número 1 y número
2 etcétera
podemos tener todas las entradas que
sean necesarias para producir el bien en
cuestión si queremos categorizar las
entradas éstas son los clásicos factores
de la producción que hemos mencionado
con anterioridad estos son la tierra
el trabajo el capital y el
emprendimiento no tiene que tener todas
estas entradas pero seguramente cada una
de estas entradas será un factor como
estos esto puede que nos siga pareciendo
algo abstracto y bastante matemático
pero para comprenderlo mejor veamos un
ejemplo más tangible imaginemos que
tenemos una operación para tostar pan lo
que hacemos es tomar pan ponerlo en una
tostadora y cuando esté tostado
terminamos cuáles son las entradas aquí
definitivamente vamos a necesitar pan
que vamos a dibujar aquí que podemos
llamar entrada y número uno también
necesitaremos al menos una tostadora que
también vamos a dibujar lo mejor que
podamos aunque realmente vamos a
necesitar varias tostadoras y digamos
que las tostadoras que usamos para esta
operación pueden tostar cuatro rebanadas
de pan al mismo tiempo y tardan diez
minutos en hacerlo y quizás se pregunten
si estas serán todas nuestras entradas
pero es obvio que el pan no va a saltar
solito a la tostadora y de regreso tiene
que existir alguien trabajando para
realizar esta operación
vamos a necesitar algunos
trabajadores en las tostadoras y digamos
que ellos pueden procesar una rebanada
por minuto sé que muchos de ustedes
piensan que esto es muy lento pero
piensen que estas personas hacen esto
todo el día con base en esto si estas
tres son las entradas necesarias para
que la salida sea una rebanada de pan
tostado podemos tratar de construir una
función de producción aquí vamos a
hacerlo la salida es el número de
rebanadas de pan tostado por ahora y va
a ser igual a vamos a escribir esto como
una función de producción mínima
limitada a varios valores veremos cuál
es el factor de la producción limitante
aunque no quiero meterme demasiado en
esto pero veremos lo necesario para
ayudarnos a comprender lo que ocurre
aquí esto es igual al mínimo de la
cantidad de pan que tenemos digamos que
tenemos rebanadas de pan porque tiene
sentido esto porque el límite de la
cantidad de pan tostado que podemos
producir va a estar determinado por la
cantidad mínima de pan sin tostar que
usamos en el proceso si tenemos
solamente 60 rebanadas de pan por hora
aquí solo podremos producir un máximo
60 rebanadas de pan tostado por ahora
todo es por ahora la otra entrada son
las tostadoras cuánto pan puede tostar
esta tostadora en una hora pues si una
tostadora tuesta cuatro rebanadas en
diez minutos lo multiplicamos por seis y
nos da 24 rebanadas tostadas por hora
ponemos 24 por el número de tostado
horas y por último pero no menos
importante cuantas rebanadas de pan
puede procesar un trabajador en una hora
serán 60 rebanadas en una hora ponemos
60 por el número de trabajadores en este
momento les invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y piensen en lo que tenemos aquí
cuáles son las entradas y cuáles las
salidas las entradas son estas de acá el
número de rebanadas de pan por hora el
número de tostadoras que tenemos
disponibles y el número de trabajadores
a las tostadoras podemos verlas como
capital a los trabajadores podemos
verlos como el factor trabajo y otra
cosa interesante a considerar de la que
hablaremos con más detalle en economía
es lo que ocurre en el corto plazo y en
el largo plazo las funciones de
producción son útiles para pensar
en el corto plazo y en el largo plazo
porque el corto plazo está definido como
la situación en la que al menos una de
las entradas está fija vamos a
escribirlo al menos una entrada es fija
qué significa esto en nuestro ejemplo
del pan tostado digamos que es bastante
sencillo obtener rebanadas de pan si
tenemos la capacidad y queremos producir
más las rebanadas de pan son un factor
que no nos va a limitar así que esta
entrada no está fija pero tener una
nueva tostadora no es tan sencillo
estas son tostadoras especiales por lo
que hay que mandarlas a hacer y tardan
un mes en entregar las así que esta
entrada tiene un mes de tiempo de espera
y digamos que para contratar más
trabajadores no hay una fila de personas
esperando listas para trabajar tenemos
que publicar ofertas de trabajo y
entrevistar personas por lo que digamos
que toma dos semanas el contratar a
alguien más o también podríamos decir
que eso se tarda en contratar o en
despedir a alguien más si quisiéramos
reducir la capacidad también digamos que
tarda un mes es tener una tostadora
nueva o el deshacerse de una tostadora
acaso el corto plazo de esta situación
es que las tostadoras las vamos a tener
fijas por lo menos un mes así que el
corto plazo aquí es de hasta un mes y
por otra parte cuál será el largo plazo
aquí por definición el largo plazo es
cuando ninguna de las entradas está fija
en donde podemos cambiar cualquiera de
estas entradas el largo plazo en este
caso va a ser mayor a un mes es
importante notar que esto solo aplica
para este ejemplo si habláramos de algún
tipo de fábrica de automóviles y la
salida fuera el número de automóviles
producidos por día o por mes y
tuviéramos las entradas como el metal o
el trabajo y tuviéramos el equipo de la
fábrica en si el largo plazo podría ser
de un año o dos o cinco años para
construir una fábrica en este caso el
largo plazo será el periodo de tiempo
mayor del necesario para construir la
fábrica por lo general es el capital lo
que tiende a ser fijo durante más tiempo
y es por eso que no es tan sencillo
tener más tostadoras hasta aquí dejamos
este tema por hoy ésta fue una
introducción al concepto de función de
producción y espero que con el ejemplo
del pan tostado
este concepto ya no sea tan intimidante
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo